if you go back uh a
couple generations uh there
the cleganes were actually kennel
masters
who uh kept the dogs for the lannisters
and there was an incident where one of
them
and several of his dogs saved one of the
the lannisters from a lion that was
attacking them
and for that reason he raised them the
knighthood and and gave them
lands which gregor controls as the elder
brother
sander has nothing but sanders a
household night he's joined
he's joined the lannisters and he's a
very very formidable warrior so they
have made him the
sworn shield of prince joffrey sanders
not a knight
i mean he has all the skills tonight he
can joust he can fight with a sword
he's very formidable but he's never said
to vows or stood a vigil
this is largely because of his hatred
for his brother
because gregor is a knight and you know
there's all these
this concept of chivalry and knights
defending the weak protecting the
innocent
all of this stuff that a knight is
supposed to do
and yet gregor is a knight this is brute
to
savage this this man subject to these
black rages who kills
and maims without the thought
and sandor coming up says
it's this knighthood is all hypocrisy
it's all a farce i'm not gonna say any
vows i mean nothing look at this my
brother is a knight and look at the kind
of man he is
so i want no part of that
honor glory lies to make idiot boys want
knight hoot
an idiot girl spread their legs for it
let me tell you what makes a knight
killing either enough men are the right
man
house clegane should know we're very
good at both
most families claim some great ancestors
so far back
that nobody can prove them lives not us
my grandfather kept the kennel for lord
titus lannister
of casterly rock the father of lord
tywin
lord titus was a weak man who didn't
know it
one day while hunting he stumbled on a
lioness
instead of embracing the man who wore
her on his banners
she tried to tear out his throat lucky
my grandfather came up with the dogs
and drove the big cat away as a reward
the clegane's got lands and a keep and a
sun to squire for the lannisters
we took the three hounds who died for
them as our new sigil
when tywin lannister became lord of
casterly rock
he wanted more from his former kennel
master than fealty
he bet the training hounds to kill isn't
far from training boys to kill
in just two generations my brother
gregor and i proved him right
i gutted my first man at 12
years after seven started disappearing
in our keep
and even a sister i don't remember
but nobody could prove anything against
gregor
or dared if they caught him at it
for my father wanted a knight in our
family
and thought he'd found one in gregor who
at 13
towered over enough men that they called
him the mountain
sure gregor looks quite the champion
from a distance
but a mountain can't cleave a man in
half with one blow
and won't break her wench's face if she
talks
through lord tywin's influence prince
rhaegar targaryen kindly anointed my
brother
personally a great honor for our family
everyone said
one year later sir gregor shiversly
sacked the prince's city
brained the prince's baby and raped and
murdered the prince's wife
winning our family yet more honor from
the new king and queen
soon after my father died
they say in a hunting accident
the same day that gregor became lord of
the clegane lands
gold and anything under his roof i left
our home to take servers
at castley rock lord tywin is not like
his father
neither is king joffrey or the likes of
me
would never be on the king's guard with
all those
true knights between them a man who
serves the lannisters
will never lack for killing
i'll guard this king such as he is
gregor will kill the other ones such as
he does
when we're done we'll see how many
people
still believe in songs and fairy tales